okay Leute wir müssen über secondh reden
woran denkst du bei secondh Klamotten
floharkt Second Hand Shops nachhaltig
coole Klamotten für ein paar Euro so ein
nettes kleines Geschäft eben zumindest
habe ich das bisher immer
gedacht aber dann habe ich bei meinen
Recherchen das gelesen secondh Boom
macht Händler zu
Milliardenunternehmen secondh Klamotten
werden zum Big Business wie Zalando
shiin und Co den Markt mit secondhand
Mode übernehmen mit einem geschätzten
Wert von 100 bis 120 Milliarden
US-Dollar weltweit hat sich der
secondhand Markt fast verdreifacht H&M
will mit selpi dieses Jahr die 100
Millionen Euro
knacken große Konzerne fast fashion
Player machen Business mit secondh wie
funktioniert das ist secondh dann
überhaupt noch nachhaltig ich bin
Sabrina das ist Big Business und ich
zeig wer die Deals macht mit deinem
[Musik]
Geld ganz ehrlich ich bin zu bequem um
mich auf den Flohmarkt zu stellen und
meine Klamotten hier zu verticken dabei
hätte es mein Kleiderschrank dringend
nötig ist schon echt ultra voll und
vielleicht könnte ich noch ein paar Euro
machen also suche ich mir eine Plattform
im Netz über die ich ein paar meiner
alten Klamotten loswerden kann auf dem
onlin Markt für secondh gibt's echt
einige eter Winter z.B der onlin
Marktplatz gehört zu den umsatzstärksten
secondhand Plattform in Europa hier kann
man Klamotten privat kaufen und
verkaufen so ähnlich funktioniert das
auch bei Momox die kooperieren übrigens
mit dem onlinemodeh Händler about you
und es gibt noch mehr große Namen
H&M
zando bei Zalando heißt das Pre auf
deine Art Kleidungstücken ein neues
Leben bis zu 20 Zalando Artikel kann ich
bei dem Online Modehändler einschicken
und bekomme dann einen Gutschein den
kann ich spenden oder was neues
einkaufen aber eben nur bei Zalando okay
damit man gleich wieder bei denen
einkauft dann fällt mir die Plattform
auf selie alles in eine Tasche den Rest
erledigen sie gib deinen Sachen eine
zweite Chance gemeinsam tun wir Gutes
für die
Umwelt part of the
change Klamotten verticken was für die
Umwelt tun und wie genau verdient selpie
damit Geld die Plattform schaue ich mir
mal genauer an also waschen bügeln und
Falten so steht's auf deren Website und
dann schleppe ich alles ins ZDF um
weiter zu
recherchieren willkommen in meinem
Büro fancy ne
so ich schaue jetzt mal was der Deal für
mich ist auf der Website von selpi kann
man testen was sie zum Verkauf anbieten
und was der Verkauf eines Artikels
ungefähr einbringen
könnte je nachdem für wie viel Kohle ein
Kleidungsstück verkauft wird bekommt
selpie einen Anteil am Verkaufspreis ist
der Preis pro Teil unter 50 € bleiben
ganze 60% bei selpie okay schauen wir
mal genauer hin angenommen ein T-Shirt
geht für 15 € Weg eine Hose für 12 und
eine Jacke für 40 € dann sind das
zusammen 67 € davon bekomme ich
26,80 € und selie 40,20 € nach Abzug der
Tasche und ein anzeigengebühr von 1 €
pro Teil bleiben 20,81 € für mich und
46,19 für selpi wobei die auch den
Versand
übernehmen also Fakt ist bleibt einiges
das Verkaufspreises bei selpie und so
langsam verstehe ich auch deren
Geschäftsmodell je mehr ich zu selelfie
recherchiere desto klarer wird mir die
Plattform ist in den letzten Jahren
krass
gewachsen selpie wurde 2014 von drei
Studienfreunden in Schweden gegründet
schon ein Jahr später stieg H&M bei den
drei Jungs ein ja richtig gehört H&M der
fast fashion Player er übernahm 2019
sogar die Mehrheit an
selpi im Laufe der Jahre soll H&M mehr
als 20 Millionen Euro in celpi
investiert haben mehr als 20 Millionen
Euro in ein Startup das mit secondh Ware
handelt mit den Finanzspritzen von H&M
konnte selpi in mehr als 20 Länder
expandieren und die secondhand Ware so
über Ländergrenzen hinweg anbieten das
Invest scheint für H&M kein so
schlechtes gewesen zu sein rund 69
Millionen Umsatz soll selpi dem Konzern
in den ersten 9 Monaten 2023 gebracht
haben okay das ist jetzt für ein
börsennotierten Konzern wie H&M nicht
gerade Big Business aber es könnte in
den nächsten Jahren ein gutes Business
werden vielleicht ist selpi auch deshalb
so schnell gewachsen weil das Prinzip
easy ist man bestellt eine Tasche mit
zwei Tüten eine grüne in die Klamotten
kommen die für ein Verkauf nicht
wertvoll genug sind die habe ich aber
deswegen nehme ich nur die blaue Tüte
hier kommen meine Klamotten rein die ich
verkaufen
möchte jetzt habe ich das so schön
gebügelt und jetzt ja super es
verknittert ja wahrscheinlich
wieder nach egal ich pack meine
Klamotten da jetzt einfach rein selfie
kümmert sich um den
Rest mal sehen was meine Tasche am Ende
bringt so 150 € hätte ich für die 15
Teile schon noch
[Musik]
gerne schick ich zur GmbH das ist die
Firma die selfie betreibt nach slzetal
bei Magdeburg und die Adresse wird
später noch
wichtig so fertig alles super bequem you
got
me außerdem tue ich ja jetzt angeblich
auch noch was gutes für die Umwelt
oder auf der Website von selp stammen
viele Artikel von fast fashion
Unternehmen wie H&M und Sara wenn ich
auf ein Produkt klicke wird mir
vorgerechnet wie viel Wasser und CO2 ich
im gleich zum Kauf eines neuen Produktes
spare
hm aber wie nachhaltig ist das Ganze
Business wirklich ich Frage sowohl sell
help als auch H&M für ein persönliches
Interview
an beide Unternehmen sagen aber relativ
schnell ab und bitten mich meine Fragen
per Mail zu stellen also schicke ich
Ihnen eine Liste mit Fragen vor allem
was genau passiert mit meinen
Klamotten und dann mache ich mich mit
unserem Team auf den den Weg nach
Reutlingen ich will mit jemandem
sprechen der sich im modebsiness gut
auskennt das ist Jochen strhele er ist
Experte für internationale
modewirtschaft und Professor an der
Hochschule
Reutlingen warum interessieren sich
onlinemodehändler und auch fast
fashionplayer wie H&M für den secondhand
Markt na die großen Konzerne wollen
natürlich attraktiv für ihre Kundinnen
und Kunden sein und Sie merken dass
gerade jüngere sehr sehr stark auf das
Thema secondhand abfahren und den Markt
den wollen Sie nicht an sich vorbeigehen
lassen und allein um attraktiv und
relevant zu sein muss man in das Thema
secondhand auch investieren und
reingehen lohnt es sich für die großen
Konzerne mehr neue Ware zu verkaufen
oder secondhand also große Konzerne
leben ja von Masse und letztenendes wenn
man sich die absoluten Zahlen anschaut
dann wird der Großteil des Geschäftes
mit klassischem Business mit klassisch
hergestellten Textilien gemacht mit mit
ersterhware secondhand Ware ist momentan
so klein dass sie überhaupt nicht
relevant ist was Ergebnisse angeht sie
dienen einzig und allein dazu momentan
Frequenz zu schaffen und das
kerngeschäftsmodell der großen Player
hat sich momentan noch nicht geändert
und der Kern des Geschäftsmodells der
sind natürlich wir wir lieben ultra
günstige Klamotten aber weil die Sachen
schnell kaputt gehen und Trends ständig
wechseln kaufen wir immer mehr
geschätzte 60 Kleidungsstücke sind
jährlich pro Kopf in Deutschland das ist
natürlich viel mehr als wir brauchen
die Konzerne werfen haufenweise
Klamotten auf den Markt teilweise eine
Kollektion pro Woche manche mehr das
sind Milliarden Kleidungsstücke im Jahr
und die bringen Milliarden
Umsätze die schwedische H&M Group mit
z.B and other stories insgesamt rund 20
Milliarden Euro
Umsatz der chinesische Konzern
chiin fast 30 Milliarden Euro Umsatz
und fast fashion Marktführer die
spanische Inditex dazu gehört z.B
berschka rund 32 Milliarden Euro
Umsatz hier liegt also das wirkliche Big
Business und es ist auch deshalb big
weil es zum Geschäftsmodell gehört dass
die Klamotten super günstig produziert
werden oft von Frauen und nicht immer
unter fairen Bedingungen die
klamottenproduktion verbraucht Mengen an
Ressourcen für ein einziges Baumwoll
T-Shirt z.B 2700 l
Wasser und die weltweite Modeindustrie
verursacht jede Menge
CO2 sie produziert sogar mehr CO2 als
die internationale Luft und
Seeschiffahrt zusammen kurz gesagt die
Modeindustrie ist extrem klimaschädlich
Big Business auf Kosten der
Umwelt und es hört nicht auf irgendwann
geben wir unsere alten Klamotten Weg ein
großer Teil der altkleiderware wird
aussortiert entferne Länder
weiterverkauft und landet dann z.B auf
afrikanischen Märkten wie diesem hier in
Kenia und auch hier kann nicht alles
verwertet werden sondern ist dann
irgendwann einfach nur noch
Müll okay zurück zum secondhand Business
der Konzerne da stellt sich doch jetzt
die Frage ob das Business dazu beitragen
könnte dass Kleidungsstücke insgesamt
länger getragen werden und damit gesamt
weniger Klamotten gekauft werden also
statistisch können wir das jetzt nicht
wirklich nachweisen was wir sehen ist
dass Konsumenten deutlich mehr
verbrauchen als vorher weil sie eben die
Möglichkeit haben über secondhand noch
mehr Produkte zu erwerben und
auszuprobieren der Grund warum man
eigentlich mehr konsumiert wenn man
secondhand nutzt häufig ist die Tatsache
dass man ja eigentlich ein festes Budget
hat man hat 50 100 200 € wie viel auch
immer im Monat zur Verfügung für
Kleidung und Textil und wenn ich ein
firthand neues Produkt kaufen möchte
dann reicht es für eins oder für zwei in
dem Moment indem ich secondh mit ins
Spiel bekomme kann ich natürlich 3 4 5
Produkte benutzen und in dem Moment
indem ich die alten secondhand auch
wieder in den Kreislauf zurückgebe
natürlich noch mal mehr und insofern
statt vielleicht 10 Kleidungsstücke 12
Kleidungsstücke pro Jahr konsumiere ich
dann 24 25 und auch die müssen alle
erstmal hergestellt sein die müssen
transportiert sein und deswegen ist es
an dieser Stelle oftmals sehr sehr
kontraproduktiv sogar
kontraproduktiv oder smartes Business je
nach Perspektive neben dem ersten Markt
also dem Verkauf unserer neuen Klamotten
verdienen die Unternehmen jetzt also
auch auf dem zweiten Markt mit unserem
secondh klamottengeld ja dann haben wir
wieder schön viel Platz im
Kleiderschrank für secondh und Neuware
das ist also der Deal fakt ist auf jeden
Fall dass secondh echt im Trend liegt
bis zum Jahr 2030 könnte secondhand 20%
Cent aller Umsätze auf dem Modemarkt
einfahre meine Klamotten sind übrigens
immer noch nicht online mich würde jetzt
echt interessieren wo die genau gelandet
sind deshalb machen wir uns auf den Weg
zu der Adresse an die ich meine
Klamotten geschickt habe Sülzetal bei
Magdeburg ich frage inzwischen noch
einmal bei selie nach was genau mit
meinen Klamotten passiert
ist so also ich würde es mal hierüber
[Musik]
gehen nee also eine 700 gibt's hier
nicht also sind meine Klamotten auch
irgendwo anders aber keine Ahnung wo als
wir weiterfahren fällt uns ein DHL
Logistikzentrum auf und sie da kurze
Zeit später kommt eine Mail von selpi um
die Logistik zu ermöglichen arbeiten wir
pro Land mit unterschiedlichen
Versanddienstleistern in Deutschland
arbeiten wir z.B mit DHL
GoGreen um unsere Kundinnen in
Skandinavien wie auch in Deutschland
bestmöglich zu bedienen betreibt selpi
ein Lager in Polen und in
Schweden also mein Eindruck ist diese
ganze Logistik um kaufen und verkaufen
ist echt aufwendig also von Mainz ging
es für meine Klamotten zu einem
Logistikzentrum nach Sülzetal von da aus
weiter nach Polen oder Schweden dort
werden Sie jetzt vielleicht irgendwo in
einem Lager sortiert fotografiert und
für den Verkauf vorbereitet der in 24
Ländern möglich ist ja und wenn meine
Klamotten nicht verkauft werden sagt
selpie werden sie in Schweden oder Polen
gespendet oder an verwertungspartner
übergeben oder ich kann sie gegen eine
Portogebühr von 5 € zurück haben dann
würden sie also wieder zurück nach meins
gekartt 2022 wurden laut selpi mehr als
als 8 Millionen secondhand Artikel
verkauft ja was für ein Aufwand fürs
Geschäft ist das secondhand Business
unter solchen Umständen überhaupt
nachhaltig vielleicht weiß sie eine
Antwort Marie Nasemann marie ist fair
fashion Aktivistin und
podcasterin natürlich ist die Frage wie
oft wird es wieder weitergeschickt und
verschickt aber grundsätzlich würde ich
schon sagen es es nachhaltiger
secondhand zu kaufen als das ein
Kleidungsstück neu produziert wird
trotzdem ist da natürlich die Frage was
für Kleidungsstücke sind das es ist sehr
viel nachhaltiger wenn man secondh kauft
die wirklich aus den 70er 80er Jahren
stammt damals wurde noch mit ganz
anderer Qualität produziert und wenn
jetzt einfach nur fast fashion
secondhand verkauft wird und Leute so
noch irgendwie privat Geld machen wovon
sie dann wieder neue fast fashion
einkaufen da fragt man sich so ein
bisschen ja wofür das ganze ein
nachhaltigeres Geschäftsmodell wäre z.B
für viel weniger Kollektion zu machen
das Tempo rauszunehmen ich glaube es
braucht ganz starke Rahmenbedingungen
von der Politik die dann in der
Wirtschaft umgesetzt werden müssen wie
z.B noch ein viel stärkeres
lieferkittengesetz und diese
Überproduktion muss auf jeden Fall
irgendwie gedeckelt werden sonst haben
wir bald ein ganz großes oder haben wir
jetzt eigentlich schon riesengroßes
Problem übrigens meine Klamotten sind
nach fast dreieinhalb Monaten immer noch
nicht online bei selfie also ein guter
Deal für mich rauskommt keine
Ahnung also das secondhand Business von
onlinemode Händlern und fast fashion
Playern könnte vielleicht ein erster
Schritt in Richtung mehr Nachhaltigkeit
sein aber es löst das Grundproblem nicht
es werden einfach viel zu viele
Klamotten produziert und
gehandelt besser wäre wenn wir z.B mehr
Klamotten tauschen oder leihen würden
oder eben nur das kaufen was wir
wirklich brauchen auch beim secondhand
Shopping danke schön
okay fakt ist dass ich fast fashion
Unternehmen mit secondhand einen zweiten
zusätzlichen Markt erschlossen haben
während sie weiterhin mit billig
produzierter Massenware Milliarden
Umsätze machen und die Folgen von diesem
Big Business sind eher kein guter Deal
für die
[Musik]
Umwelt